the Inspector General of the Department
of Justice announced today that the DOJ
has opened an investigation into spying
possibly illegal spying on American
citizens by the federal government law
professor Jonathan Turley will explain
the legal implications of that brewing
scandal in just a minute but first to
fox chief national correspondent Edie
Henry who's been following this all day
for more details head
Tucker great to see you initially
Democrats like Adam Schiff laughed off
these allegations about FISA abuse but
tonight some in the Obama inner circle
as well as former top FBI officials like
James Comey and Andrew McCabe may be
sweating a bit because this is heating
up now with the Justice Department
Inspector General Michael Horowitz
saying he's going to take a close look
at it and remember Attorney General Jeff
Sessions had said he wanted Horowitz to
handle this and and sessions got a lot
of heat from supporters of President
Trump who said the Inspector General
would bury this and that this was
sessions passing the buck again but this
is a sign Horowitz is moving full speed
ahead on what Republican Devon Nunez
first revealed with his memo laying out
how top FBI and justice officials in the
Obama administration got a warrant from
the FISA Court to spy an X Trump advisor
Carter page most importantly Comey
McCabe and other officials allegedly
used former British by Christopher
Steele's anti-trump dossier to get that
initial warrant without telling the
judge that the DNC and Hillary Clinton's
campaign had paid for the dirt in that
dossier
now Horowitz is already working on two
other major reports including commis
conduct FBI agent Peter struck text
messages and McCabe's unauthorized
leaked to the media we should note that
just this very week there had also been
criminal charges filed in Minnesota in a
separate case involving a former FBI
agent who allegedly leaked classified
sensitive information and so the bottom
line is this is also part of jeff
sessions crackdown on the leaking of
sensitive information of big development
tonight tucker it sure is ed Henry
thanks for that good to see Jonathan
Turley is a law professor at George
Washington University Law School in
Washington joins us too many professor
thanks for coming on thank you so it's I
mean it's the gravest of all charges the
federal government potentially spying
illegally on American citizens why only
now
is the IG looking into this well you
know there's been an interesting
phenomenon here a lot of people who have
rightfully criticized those that want to
shut down the Special Counsel
investigation right but those same
people often belittle these allegations
about what happened in this secret court
and it's a dangerous combination to have
a secret court that is based on a
standard lower than the Fourth Amendment
that is totally secret and insulated
from public review if that court is also
used for political agenda now we don't
know if that's true but we have
worrisome facts that should be looked at
and so whatever but I think is missing
in Washington is this sense of balance
both sides should be investigated these
are troubling issues that are raised by
both Republicans and the Democrats what
happened today is that we're going to be
guaranteed that the there will be an
independent investigation and [ __ ]
which is the perfect guy to do it I mean
he knows the DOJ he's very
well-respected and I think that what
we're going to learn from this process
could help us in the future what would
he be looking at he's going to be
looking specifically at that application
with Carter page you know many people
made fun a president Trump when he said
that his campaign was under surveillance
and people like former director clapper
said I would have known if there was an
order of surveillance what turns out
there were multiple orders of
surveillance and they not just the first
q separate there clapper said that
mocked the idea clapper has been caught
lying to the public before is there any
way to read this other than as
dishonesty well I don't know what
clapper was thinking of but what we do
know is that there was not just one but
a renewal of these orders that's a very
serious question to look at and when you
have someone who's associated with the
opposing party's campaign for president
now a judge did look at this and did say
that it warranted a renewal but that
application while it said that one of
these sources was political in nature
didn't reveal everything that the FBI
knew about the dossier that it was
funded by the Clinton campaign that it
found that much of the dossier was not
cooperated that there were serious
questions about the motivation and the
fact that Steele himself tried to shop
this to the media and had told Anna
justice official that he really didn't
like
and want to do everything he could that
he wouldn't be president those are
material facts now does that mean that
the court became an adjunct of the DNC
or was caught up in a political agenda
we don't know but the point is that the
American people have a right to know if
this very powerful court was used for
inappropriate or abusive reasons
have you noticed since you've briefly
since you've covered and taught the law
in the city for a long time a decline in
the concern over civil liberties of
Americans in Washington you know I have
we've almost become numb first of all
people have really low expectation of
their government now and that's a real
shame but the FISA Court itself has
always been a concern for civil
libertarians because of its standard
because of its insularity
so when this scandal focused on the FISA
Court it was a huge concern because
abuses in that court arm can be
magnified in terms of their damage yes
because it is so insulated it is so
secret and it's capable of doing a lot
more it without people seeing it than a
normal court I think it's terrifying but
essentially anyway professor thank you
for that appreciate it